foreign
let's chat it up with Ray it's a shame
about Ray what's up Ray
hey John I can't put him on your show
right now dude I can't believe you're
talking to me this is awesome
I just appreciate it I mean you've saved
my my wife and I thousands of dollars in
therapy so just by your show alone so I
appreciate
um actually getting to be beyond your
your show so I appreciate you having the
courage to give me a buzz dude so what's
up man I I mean it I don't really know
where to start
um so I'm hoping you can kind of lead me
with as I pose the question kind of lead
the conversation so I feel like there's
a lot behind it okay
um but
I just find it difficult to let myself
cry
even when I'm like my body is telling me
I need to
I just like you know even in a quiet
place it just doesn't happen and it's
not like you know when I'm watching a
good movie like or grateful for my
family and all like I can the tears come
a little bit of that but it's like when
I'm dealing with
um like loss or stress or like shame or
disappointment in myself or just sadness
and it just doesn't come so I'm hoping
you can guide me to know what to do
give me an example of a Time
when you were thinking in real time I
should be crying right now and I want to
cry but I can't
give me a specific example
so when I this happened actually just a
couple days ago
um and it's like little experiences like
this that kind of add up
um that lead me to like feel that build
and I just doesn't come so like my son
he loves the projector we have we call
it projector night where he you know we
we put it up on the wall and and all
that he wanted to put it up a new place
he's three years old by the way
um so he we put up a show and people
wanted to put a new spot spot wasn't big
enough to fit the screen you know but
he's pushing all the buttons and I'm
trying to take it down and up and I lose
a little bit of my my cool not like
hardcore not yelling at him or anything
like that but just like like but we
gotta you know almost like I was blaming
him it's like dude he's three
but it shouldn't push my buttons like
that but then I then I go into the shame
cycle
where I start beating myself up
and I'm
feel this like heaviness and I apologize
to him you know sound like I feel sad
that I reacted that way I chose to react
that way sorry but I'll be better next
time or
um but man it is that and then I do
something a little something else or
like I don't do as good at work and I
feel this like if I don't do a good job
on a project or whatever
it then builds up and I just start to
feel that
and I don't have like I don't take time
as much as I should maybe to to sit and
just be alone with it but even then it
doesn't always come
man you you are describing your life as
though you're watching a movie of
yourself critiquing it
and
brother I gotta tell you man that that
is the quintessential
that's the quintessential definition of
trauma is separation from your oneself
who told you man
that the way you do life is wrong
because when I hear a guy I hear a guy
that is
like so far ahead
of millions and millions of men dads
husbands trying to do
better than what they got
but there's this voice in the stands
that just won't let you get better
the inner critic it's like the judge so
yeah but that inner critic that's
somebody's voice whose voice is that
um I
probably my my parents
um
you've been defending them for way too
long they're grown-ups they can take
care of themselves
yeah I have them you gotta stop
I know
but you know yeah I mean for example
like when I was a kid you know when I
when I'd cry this is something that came
to my mind like my dad would be like
here comes the fire engine make you cry
more you know and then
why did he make you cry more
because it was like it didn't matter to
him no no no no no no that's not it
you cried more
because when you were hurting you needed
one thing
and that was a dad who saw you and said
come here buddy
yeah and damn it he didn't give you that
and in fact he widened the Gulf
he made that Chasm between the two of
you wider and he looked at you and
blamed you here comes the fireworks here
comes the fire trucks
yeah and so it's it's kind of like being
in the water
and you realize it's too deep you can't
touch and you start panicking and your
dad makes eye contact with you and swims
away
that's why you cried harder I came from
your guts
see what I'm saying I I do and I bet
that happened in high school too
were you a kid that got good grades and
then the the first response is
wow would another of a have killed you
well I'm
honey I was homeschooled and I was
pulled out really young and and had no
structure with this Cooling and it was
like here's a math book see ya I'm gonna
go teach piano lessons and I'm like okay
I'll try to learn how to do this so I
had no structure really no help in that
regard
um but were you judged as though you did
it yeah it was like why you know you
need to be doing this and it's like
critical and not like
I know
it was yeah it was very much like here
set me up didn't really set me up for
success
um but I mean there were some great
blessings that came from that here you
go stop defending them for sure for five
minutes I don't know five minutes no I I
am a I am a perfect example of that I
yeah
I also had to be there for my mom I mean
my parents are divorced I had to carry a
lot of her worries and or I chose to or
she put them on me no you didn't know
what to do kids don't choose
you didn't
that became your job and your role
so how do I
what do I do now like as much as it's
like okay I can I've been I have like
novel sized notes in my phone
of everything of how breaking it down
and you know trying to make sense of it
all but in the end it's like okay but I
can try and make sense of it but what do
I do now it's like
I can't really
it doesn't do me much good just simply
knowing what happened it's like well I'm
dealing with this now so what do I do
how do I how do I allow myself to feel
again feel that that vulnerability like
to be truly vulnerable
in my own skin and be okay
regardless of I don't want like
validation from others to cry I don't
want to have to put on Sarah Mclaughlin
to cry or I want to be able to just like
allow myself to cry
okay first I want you to unhook yourself
from crying being this magic Finish Line
okay
so
similar to like somebody who's been
working in the real world for 10 years
and they have an MBA and they're telling
me they need to go back to get a PhD in
business so they can learn how to do
business better I want to tell you man
at this point you can just you you can
just get what you need off the internet
so it's a false Finish Line okay
okay I don't want that to be your marker
because what's going to happen is you're
going to cry and you're still going to
be sad you're just gonna be frustrated
you're still gonna feel like the inside
of your chest is cemented shut and all
of your guts have been super glued
together which is like which is how you
feel
and crying well
crying is the result of the work crying
isn't the destination Okay so
uh I'm running through my head here
I'll be as vague as I can
um
[Music]
last time I prefer specific if you need
if you're asking me no no no I'm trying
to decide how much I'm going to disclose
here
um I'll just it we're here so last week
um I've been seeing a counselor
um halfway through writing this last
book I was brought back to some memories
and stories in my life that I had
evidently
buried far far away and I knew him I
knew I didn't think about him very much
and it was uh like getting hit by a
truck
and I know him
I'm write them down like you I've got
pages and pages in my notes app on my
phone and in my little diary Journal
things
and then for the first time in 40 years
I spoke it out loud in front of a
counselor
and I felt
oh I can't describe it other than I'm
still processing it
but I felt like I dropped a hundred
pounds
and then I went home and I had a
conversation and I've been married to
the same woman for 20 years we've been
together for probably 25 26 now and I
had never told her some of this stuff
and yet another 100 pounds so I tell you
this there is only one path to
vulnerability
and that is sitting in front of somebody
else who could burn you who could hurt
you
and you saying here's what happened
that's the path
yeah
and I don't know how it works I'm sure
there's an oxytocin release and I'm sure
partrogen a pear tree and dopamine and
serotonin and jumping jacks and cold
tubs I'm sure all that crap is a thing I
don't care
what I know beyond a shadow of a doubt
from the research but I know beyond a
shadow of a doubt for my own life what I
know beyond a shadow of Doubt from last
week
is that
the thing that melts the cement in your
chest
is sitting across somebody and saying
this happened to me
that's why every major religion
throughout all of human history has a
confession element to it and we've made
confession about bad things we did
that's not the origin of confession
confession the origin of confession is
here's what happened
and I think it's been woven through
every religion throughout human history
because it's a it's it's got a healing
element to it it's medicinal
for lack of better terms it's spiritual
it's a gift
are there things that you've experienced
that your wife doesn't even know
yeah not specifics you know some general
General uh
things haven't gotten into the dirt of
it all
have you ever sat down with a counselor
and just said hey this is what happened
no no well I mean some things but not
not the stuff like not this stuff that's
right
and what you're trying to do is I want
you to follow the pattern here you're
having a conversation with yourself
it's reinforced by your younger self
that then turns your body up and starts
spinning and then you've got to have a
conversation to bring yourself back down
and you're in a loop-de-loop and another
word for loop-de-loop is a hurricane or
a tornado
and that my friend is anxiety
and then you find yourself trying to
predict what she's gonna say what what's
going to happen over here if your boss
emails you at 4 pm in the afternoon you
can't breathe
yeah yeah and that needs to happen
bro I mean
uh
crying's good for me crying is cathartic
the other day I was um
I don't mind we're just gonna tell all
delony's laundry we're just gonna put
all out there today
um I went to Texas for an event for a
couple of days working with a really
remarkable business and I got to sit
with a couple of buddies who have been
my rider dies for almost 30 years now
and their wives I consider them some of
my best friends it's we're a gang and we
all went out to dinner with just me and
my two buddies and their two wives just
us no kids and I secretly handed my
debit card to the waitress under the
table pay for the whole meal
and I've had a season of blessing in the
last year it's been silly we sold a lot
of books and a lot of questions for
humans cards
and my buddy John King looked at me
and he said you will never do that again
and I said hey man it's been a good
season I've had a good little run here
y'all picked me up for years these are
guys these two guys paid my rent
and he said you have to have a place
where you can pull up to a table
and we love you because you're you not
because you're buying us dinner never do
that again
and I was telling my wife this story
when I got back to Nashville
and I just started weeping in a
restaurant
it just came
because I was overwhelmed by how much
those four people love me
and they don't care how famous and they
don't care they don't care anything
because they were my friends they loved
me when they were paying my rent
one of those guys I had to call one time
and say hey I've got like a real bad
issue with my health and I may need to
go to the ER and I've Got No Room on a
credit card can I borrow your Southwest
card to go to the ER
and he said I'll drive you
that's how poor and you see what I'm
saying but I was so overwhelmed but the
goal wasn't to cry at that lunch
the guy was the goal was to say out loud
to somebody that I care and love my wife
I can't believe how blessed I am
and I can't believe I've got people that
I don't have to prove myself to
yeah I feel like I I don't I mean other
than my wife that's the best person to
be able to do this with
but I if you talk about having guy
friends I don't have guy friends I mean
it's been I need guy friends too so like
when you when you talk about that like
you'll be able to sit down with dinner
it's not about what you can offer them
you know it's just like
you yeah you are enough you know we tell
the same stories for 30 years yeah
here's the deal
how old are you now
I'm 33 33.
you've got
I I don't know you start today
and you'll be having this conversation
when you're 53 and you've been riding or
dying with a group of guys for 20 years
it's easier when they shove you all in a
college dorm and say May the force be
with you right May the odds be forever
in your favor and you don't have that
luxury
but you got money now right you've got
like a car
and it's just a matter of starting the
challenge for you is those kind of
relationships
burned you alive as a kid man
and my guess is you and I could talk for
a long time and
you're trying to navigate a mom who used
you like a water bottle usually as a
drug right you were oxygen for her and a
dad that was so critical of his own
freaking son man
that he mocked his pain laughed at him
because your cries were annoying and too
loud like a fire truck engine
my guess is you've probably made some
dumb mistakes along the way trying to
find connection with anybody anywhere or
any place anyhow and you ultimately
learned I'm just gonna
take my tools and go home
it's hard
tears will come
but I want you to focus your energy on
vulnerability
on finding a person
a couple of people that you can just be
honest with for the first time
for me that needed to be a professional
I need to sit down and say hey this
stuff happened
and
it was just like the glue melted man
and my my dearest hope for you my
brother my neighbor here in town is that
you'll have the courage to make those
calls
sit down with your wife and say hey I
have some dark stuff I'd love to tell
you about but it's also going to be
heavy so you tell me when you're ready
because she can feel that disconnection
between the two of you two
you're worth
connecting
I'm grateful for you my brother hang on
the line I'm gonna send you a copy of
own your past change your future for
free
um read that it'll give you a blueprint
out
I'm grateful for you man thanks for
trying to be the best husband and Dad
you can be
now I want you to take that level of
care and look in the mirror and love
that guy that much too